Traduttore: Massimo Garzotto
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Sono qui per raccontarvi un esperimento
che ho iniziato a fare cinque anni fa.
Mi sono seduta al computer e ho scritto
una mail a tutti i miei contatti
nella quale, in sostanza,
chiedevo loro di fare tre cose:
la prima, di smettere di fare
quello che stavano facendo;
la seconda, di guardarsi intorno;
la terza, di scegliere un oggetto.
Ma l’'oggetto doveva essere scelto
secondo il principio della parità,
cioè  la scelta doveva ricadere
su qualche cosa
che non suscitasse sentimenti
di superiorità o di inferiorità,
al contrario, qualcosa di percepito
come vicino, cordiale, amico:
insomma, un oggetto alla pari.
Per spiegarmi, personalmente
non potrei scegliere alla pari
un vocabolario di latino,
poiché non mi esprimo in latino,
non uso il latino,
pur avendolo studiato,
ma posso scegliere con una certa
spontaneità, e sentirmi a mio agio,
e quindi alla pari, con una caffettiera.
Cio è io con una moka del caff è
posso addirittura pensare di parlare.
Poi la mail continuava
chiedendo alle persone
di venire nel mio studio
con l’'oggetto scelto
e di raccontarmi i motivi
che avevano portato a questa scelta.
Nel frattempo,
io avrei fatto delle foto.
Ebbene, hanno risposto
all'’invito 24 persone.
Chi è  venuto piů convinto,
chi titubante, chi curioso,
ognuno con il proprio oggetto.
Per esempio Alberto.
Alberto ha scelto
una molletta del bucato
e in questa immagine
sta parlando del rispetto di sé.
Oppure Gabriella, che è un'’appassionata
di macchine sportive,
sceglie un modellino
di macchina, la sfida
e in quest'immagine sta parlando
del piacere della lentezza.
O ancora Andrea,
che si sta domandando:
cosa ci sto facendo qui
con una melanzana?
Però è  l'’oggetto giusto!
Loris invece sceglie
un megafono costruito a mano,
lo guarda, lo osserva
e in quest'immagine
sta ascoltando
la sua voce profonda.
Oppure Chiara,
che addenta la vita
e con la sua scarpa
parla di amore e di famiglia.
Allora cominciavo a vedere
che quello che io avevo immaginato
dava i suoi frutti,
e cioè che un oggetto,
per il fatto di essere scelto,
restituisce qualcosa
di colui o colei
che ha operato la scelta.
E quindi la scelta diventa
un atto comunicante.
Però non era sufficiente,
perché le persone in questione
mi conoscevano già,
quindi c'era un rapporto.
Allora ho riscritto tutto
sotto forma di progetto d'arte,
l'ho chiamato "Discorso Alla Pari"
e l'ho presentato
in altri contesti sociali,
come il mondo delle imprese,
o l'Università o il teatro.
Qui avete il risultato ottenuto
in alcune aziende.
Ho incontrato un centinaio di persone
che svolgevano mansioni diverse
dal fattorino, all'’impiegato,
l'’operaio, l’'amministratore delegato.
E qui mi sono convinta
della bontà dell'’idea.
Ma per entrare più nel dettaglio
e spiegarvi che cosa scatena,
quale dinamica si attua
nel momento in cui scegliamo
un oggetto percepito alla pari,
vi racconto di questo ragazzo.
Dunque, mi trovo
in una tipografia
e il suo mestiere
è quello dello stampatore,
infatti porta
un utensile, per lui,
cioè le spatole
per stendere l'inchiostro.
Nella stampa tipografica
i colori sono quattro:
- ciano, magenta, giallo e nero-
e dello stesso colore sono le spatole.
Dunque mi trovo in fabbrica,
c’ 'è un'’area dedicata al progetto,
sto aspettando il prossimo oggetto,
lui entra con aria molto distante
e subito va al dunque e mi dice:
sappi che io non ho letto molti libri,
però so una cosa che tu non sai.
So di che colore è l'alba,
perché la vedo tutte le mattine,
mi alzo molto presto per venire al lavoro.
E vedo che l'alba non è mai uguale.
Anche fosse per una piccola
sfumatura, è sempre diversa.
Anche io ho diverse sfumature’.
E comincia a usare le spatole.
Ho il rosso che è
la parte di me che trattengo,
la rabbia, quella che non esprimo;
ma allo stesso tempo
ho il giallo-arancio
che è la parte di me
più cordiale,
quella che sta bene
con gli altri;
poi ho il blu che è
la parte più riflessiva,
quella anche più melanconica,
quella che pensa però;
e poi ho il nero, che   la parte di me
che mi fa paura, quella in ombra.
Ecco vedi, mettere insieme tutte
queste sfumature
per me non è facile.’
E fa un discorso alla pari
sul carattere.
Allora vedete come, nel momento,
- la scelta è importante,
dal momento in cui il mio sentimento
si dirige verso un oggetto,
fino a quando scelgo
e decido che è quello giusto
e poi di conseguenza agisco,
ne parlo, lo motivo, faccio le foto,
ecco, tutto questo, insieme,
restituisce uno straordinario
autoritratto.
In altri termini, nella misura
in cui noi scegliamo,
in accordo con la nostra parte
più profonda,
nel rispetto della nostra indole,
riusciamo a far emergere
la parte di noi
più bella, più efficace.
Perché ho fatto tutto questo?
Perché circa cinque anni fa
mi sono trovata a prendere
una decisione per me molto delicata:
se abbandonare la mia
professione artistica
per ragioni economiche
- avevo perso i miei contratti più
importanti ed ero rimasta senza lavoro;
–oppure persistere nonostante le
previsioni più nere.
E finché stavo pensando
queste cose,
con lo sguardo perso
in un orizzonte che non vedevo,
avevo un fiore tra le mani.
E il fiore ha cominciato a parlarmi.
E questo vi da l'idea dello stato d'animo:
parlavo coi fiori, ero persa.
Ma il fiore mi ha risposto,
materialmente!
E mi ha detto una
cosa interessante, cio è:
io sono una gerbera, sono rossa,
vado bene così, mi piaccio.
O forse dovrei essere un tulipano?
Ho dato ascolto al fiore,
ho deciso di seguire la mia indole,
ho deciso di persistere:
e questo mi ha dato la forza
per risalire la china,
e come potete immaginare
ha anche ispirato il progetto
di cui vi sto parlando
che è diventato, nel tempo,
parte del mio lavoro.
Quindi, confermo quello
che ho intuito all'inizio,
e cioè che scegliere in accordo
con la propria profonda natura
non fa che far emergere
la parte di noi veramente più attiva,
più vincente addirittura,
e vi invito a farlo.
Provate adesso,
più tardi, domani.
Pensate a un oggetto,
sceglietelo,
ascoltatelo, domandatevi
perché l’'avete scelto.
Ciò che conta è, però,
che la scelta sia fatta
completamente alla pari.
Grazie!
(Applausi)